all-star weekend is more than just a
game in a dunk competition give me an
example of the breadth of the coverage
you guys get both TV and digital oh my
god we are we're covering this from a
digital perspective on nba.com bleacher
report we're covering it on NBA TV we're
covering on TNT we're simulcasting this
year the the all-star game itself on
Sunday both on TBS and TNT we have this
year our first time we're having a
fashion show with supermodels and NBA
players being judged by Charles Barkley
and Kenny which I think will be
interesting we have Kevin Hart doing
some back back stuff behind stage stuff
at the fashion show how much we got a
lot of things how much bigger is the
all-star weekend or week because it's in
New York I think it just steps it up
miss is the you know I always say New
York's the mecca of basketball and even
though the teams here don't win yeah
unfortunately picture having a tough
tough season or a couple of seasons but
still this is where people come the mad
square garden is still the place where
people go and think about basketball now
we have a new Barclays Center in
Brooklyn so it's kind of exciting going
to two different cities in two different
places and getting everybody hyped up
for the weekend seeing that you're
offering this digital experience do you
see yourself making Turner a destination
where you're going to be streaming
eventually well we stream now I mean you
can get the games with TV everywhere
with all of our cable operators and
satellite partners you can actually
stream and get the game as long as you
authenticate for TV Everywhere but you
know bleacher report's covering this and
NBA com is covering highlights clips
Twitter but would you ever go direct to
consumer I think eventually listen you
know subscription is going to be an
interesting part of our business for the
future I think that you're going to have
never speak that never sign up for cable
you're going to have some cord shavers
which actually reduce go down and take a
smaller package so we've got to get
ourselves to a direct consumer situation
not to hurt our relationship with our
cable operators at all but to figure out
a way to live in both in both
communities the New World Order I know
it gets your goat that some of your
competitors are touting over the top now
like we've been there for a long time
with this very package yeah yeah we will
be the leap bass package
over the top it's been over the top four
years but but I think you were talking
about the Turner properties in itself
we're we're part of the sling TV package
now with dish four of our five of our
networks including adult swim is part of
it and but it's not affecting the
day-to-day meaning I need to be in the
smaller bundle packages as well as the
larger packages and if I can do both
that's that's that's where would you
rather be the sports with the
acquisition costs where they are or
can't you come up with a Walking Dead of
your own I'd like to do both can't I
have both can't have it all sports
drives listen George Sports is live no
one watches I always say no one watches
in Super Bowl on Monday right so and
this weekend between the slam dunk
competition the all-star game people are
going to tune in to watch the live event
and that's something that you can't
replicate you can't change so sports
drives hopefully subscription revenue
penetration for your for your networks
advertising dollars and and it works on
mobile and any other device does that
mean there's no limit to what you'll pay
for sports program that can see those
numbers just keep getting higher and
we've got to ask ourselves in the call
when does it not make sense and the
pipeline the cost does no matter what
the operators say the cost does come
down I have my time one or bill to prove
it it does come down to me at home yeah
well listen I don't I can't say what
time owners gonna be charging you are
not charging what kind of bundles you're
being put in there is listen every
single sports deal we do at Turner and
I'm sure at every company you have
financial responsibilities so we believe
every deal that we've gone into at the
end of that deal we're going to make a
profit and we make a profit either
through our digital assets our mobile
assets our subscription revenue you are
advertising dollars our off-site stuff
like this fact the fashion shows and
event marketing that we do whether with
our advertiser and so but you figure out
how to encumber all of it and figure out
how to make money from them then what's
the next big sports right package that
you want to bring to TBS we would love
at some point hopefully to bring back
the NFL if we could financially to our
network and hopefully that package
becomes available at some point but
that's realistically it's not going to
come
I hope so I don't skip will be on later
he'll say no it will not become knowable
at any time so in the network's
certainly in the past NBC gave up and
then jump right back in they see the
value in the NFL listen NFL is still the
largest you know a way to accumulate
audiences right it's it's it's it's
probably one of the best sports
properties from from a standpoint of
ratings in the business and belen
Rodgers just leave Canada that they buy
the team they bought maple leaf sports &
entertainment to drive just mobile
product and tablet product yeah that's
where we're all headed right it's
everything is mobilizing we are in our
company we're focused really focused on
mobile you know these devices that
everybody has this is where you're going
to be able to communicate this is we're
going to be watching your content and we
don't look at it anymore as television
right we look at it as video screens
right I don't mind the television
finished business anymore i'm actually
in the content creation and distribution
business but isn't everybody right now
in the content business the content
business at some point we've got to say
a lot of this contents just not that
good well some is summarizing right but
you know hopefully the premium content
developers are the ones that are going
to win right i mean these devices don't
work without great content right and so
if you take a look at the social scene
right now people what are they talking
about they're talking about the grammys
they're talking about the oscars they're
talking about the Super Bowl right and
that's what to communicate and those are
all television quality events right so a
lot of these devices that are working
and discussing in the social sorry the
social communication is about the things
that are on television some of the cable
operator getting nervous these days
because I almost you don't need them
anymore at least ten years down the road
you might not you know listen you still
need broadband right you still need
other things in just the video screen so
the cable operators are thinking about
ways how they're going to make their new
there are new dollars their new prophets
and maybe it comes from the broadband
side versus the video side our ad
revenues dropping because there's too
many screens there's too many options
for place for advertisers I think
advertisers are starting to get involved
much more with target marketing with the
data information that they're getting so
they're trying to seek the right place
to put it and it's not just you know
these to say well what's the line needs
to say fifty percent of your advertising
works and fifty percent doesn't now they
get
a more accurate to see what works and
the place of their dollars there